I don't know where this trend came from
but if you are terminally online as I am
much to my shame then then except on the
weekends then you are already well aware
of it at some point over the past week
or so it came to my attention uh it came
to the attention of many women rather on
social media that the men in their lives
frequently think about the Roman Empire
this was a shock to women most of whom
have never had a single unprompted
thought about the Roman Empire or
frankly any ancient empire much to their
shame at any point in their lives and so
Instagram Twitter and Tick Tock soon
became flooded with videos of women
asking their husbands and boyfriends
whether they think about this subject
and how often
here's just a quick compilation of a few
of these um fascinating conversations
watch
the Roman Empire
what do I think about it yeah
it's technically
like do you think about the Roman Empire
ever
how often
once a week how do you not think about
the Roman Empire
how many times
like a week or just how many times in
general do you think about the Roman
Empire
what about the room just anything about
it
probably not a lot why not a lot when
was the last time you thought about it
maybe a week or two ago
the Roman Empire was a very big part in
history so how often do you think about
it
not a lot how often
once every month maybe three or four
times a month you think about the Roman
Empire once a week it has a lot of big
like
stories and lessons like within the
Roman Empire of what to do and what not
to do so yeah so you think about the
Roman Empire once a week sometimes yeah
a Roman Empire
I don't know every couple days
so this has uh
pick the interest of the media as well
the Daily Mail people Business Insider
wire the New York Times Time Magazine
Rolling Stone Mashable among others have
all run lengthy articles about this
phenomenon each attempting to offer some
sort of explanation for why men think
about the Roman Empire and women not
only don't think about it but are
shocked to learn that anyone thinks
about it at all now
before I offer my own analysis I should
answer the question for myself I don't
think about the Roman Empire quite as
often as many of these other men the
Roman Empire probably crosses my mind a
few times a month but no more than that
and that's because the historical Epoch
that I devote most of my mental energy
to is the American Old West so I think
about the old west multiple times a day
easily there are other historical
periods and episodes that I reflect on
frequently I think about Magellan's
circumnavigation of the globe at least
once a week probably more the age of
Discovery in general is a subject of
daily meditation loyal listeners of this
show also know that I have a strange
obsession with 19th and early 20th
century polar exploration that's a
period of history that I easily think
about every day I think the point is
that men all have certain historical
episodes that they tend to mull over the
Roman Empire makes it into all of our
rotations but its frequency can vary
depending on how much psychological real
estate we give to other time periods now
let me solve the mystery for the
confused women of the world why do men
think about these things well the
shortest and simplest answer is that we
think about stuff like this because it's
interesting to think about I mean what
else is there to think about sure there
are plenty of other things to think
about on a daily basis I also think
about outer space and the deep sea the
Amazon rainforest I think about what I
would do I think all guys think about it
what would I do if a bunch of bad guys
with guns came to kill me really like in
any scenario in any like physical
environment I walk into you you think
about that you run through the various
scenarios one where you have a gun
yourself one where you're unarmed one
where you're armed only with nunchucks
or a hammer or a chainsaw or something
um think about that I think about my own
death I think about what's for dinner
the point is that there's a lot of time
in the day to think about a lot of
things and I read somewhere that the
human brain process is 70 000 thoughts
in a day and that seems completely made
up to me I don't know how anyone could
come up with an exact number of thoughts
that the average person thinks I'm not
even sure how you precisely
differentiate one thought from the next
but I'm sure that we all well some of us
anyway
uh do plenty of thinking and we think
about many things why wouldn't we carve
out some time
to think about ancient Rome like I said
it's interesting that's really the only
prerequisite for determining whether
something is worth thinking about as far
as men are concerned there's more to it
than that though in the Roman Empire we
see much to admire this was a
civilization that helped to build the
world as we know it today they invented
or helped to innovate everything from uh
aqueducts to to complex systems of roads
to concrete uh they built enormous
beautiful structures like the Coliseum
and the pantheon which still stand to
this day
like any great ancient civilization
their priorities extended beyond the
moment that they're living in unlike us
they actually remembered things that
happened more than 30 minutes ago and
they thought about the future Beyond 30
minutes from now
they cared about Legacy they wanted to
build a civilization that would last for
a thousand years and they did
so it's the longevity the permanence the
Legacy that we admire and that we look
to with a certain longing pangs of
sadness upon the realization that our
own civilization is so feckless and limp
and
shallow and superficial and distracted
by comparison
the Roman Empire was also a time like in
any ancient civilization where what we
would call traditional masculinity
Reigns Supreme men were men and were
rewarded and celebrated for being men
these are the things we think about when
we think about the Roman Empire the
Roman Empire is also a warning it's a
cautionary tale that we are certainly
not heeding in our age
after all it's it's it's the Roman
Empire is no longer with us because it
eventually fell it collapsed
and given that we are very much seeming
to be living through our own
civilizational collapse we like to go
back and read about and think about
other civilizations that experience the
same so that we know what to expect and
so that by some miracle we might be able
to Stave off the inevitable so it's both
the parallels with our time and the
differences that we find fascinating
it's just unfortunate that we share all
of the bad features of ancient Rome and
few of the good ones before getting our
dog rough grains he was so sad and lazy
now he actually enjoys his squeaky toys
and playing Fetch with his frisbee our
pups days are filled with laughter
exercise and endless fun naturopathic Dr
Dennis black founder of rough grains is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America little did I know before
I got rough grains dog food is dead food
everyone knows that nutrition isn't
Brown it's green let rough grains boost
your dog's food back to life rough
grains is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners have
where are raving about rough grains it
supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we and that goes for
dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis black is
so confident rough greens will improve
your dog's health he's offering my
listeners a free jumpstart trial bag so
your dog can try a free jump start trial
bag could be at your door in just a few
business days go to roughgreens.com Matt
or call 844 rough 700 that's
ruffgreens.com Matt or call 844 rough
700 today
I think the bigger question and the more
interesting one is though why women are
surprised to learn that men think about
these kinds of things
now the answer is I believe partly that
a woman will very often ask the man in
her life what are you thinking and the
man will almost never reply by saying
the Roman Empire or any other historical
subject in fact the man will often say
quote nothing
which has led many women to the
understandable but still mistaken
conclusion that men often sit around
thinking about literally nothing at all
well they don't understand is that when
we say nothing
what we really mean is nothing relevant
to you or nothing we feel like talking
about at the moment
we aren't going to say oh I'm thinking
about the Roman Empire because we know
that'll lead to a whole list of
additional questions that will take us
totally away from the train of thought
that we're on
so real world example of this
um a few days ago I was sitting and
staring blankly into space as one tends
to do it and my wife asked me what are
you thinking about and the real answer
is that I was thinking about where I
would rank Christopher Nolan in a list
of the top 20 film directors of all time
which is a thought that came to mind
when I thought about his film
Interstellar which is overrated in my
opinion an Interstellar came to mind
because before that I was thinking about
what might actually happen if I fell
into a black hole and I didn't want to
explain all of that so instead I said
nothing
now women might consider that kind of
answer dishonest but from a man's
perspective we don't see how we can be
expected to Simply reveal the contents
of our mind upon request and we also
can't say you know the real honest
answer would be I guess well I don't
want to tell you what I'm thinking
because if we say that then the woman's
gonna either assume that we're planning
some kind of big surprise or we're
concealing some dark secret like we're
planning a birthday a surprise ready bug
or we're having an affair those are the
two things she's going to assume and
neither of those assumptions will do us
or our relationship any good so that's
where this comes from but there's
another reason why women are surprised
by this Roman Empire thing and this is
the most important part
a woman's mind simply Works differently
from a man's mind of man tends to think
more abstractly about things that are
Beyond his immediate experiences and
environment a woman
and her thoughts are more situated in
her daily life her relationships her
home her emotions the emotions of people
closest to her for example my wife
spends more time in a day thinking about
furniture
then I have cumulatively in my entire
life
so like Furniture is is the Roman Empire
to women basically
um and neither of these ways of thinking
are wrong obviously they're just
different
and they're different in important ways
ways that also happen to complement one
another
you know it's almost as though men and
women were designed to pair up and go
through life together imagine that the
man with his sort of larger abstract
meditations the woman with her more
grounded and immediate and often
emotion-based concerns and together the
two have all the bases covered after all
it's important to have somebody in the
family who's worried about the decline
of Empires and the fate of human
civilization it's also important to have
someone who's worried about the fact
that the baby needs a new onesie
so different ways of thinking for two
different sexes
yet more evidence in the end that the
Sexes do in fact exist and that they are
in fact definable and different in ways
that even transcend the physical
which is why ultimately it's once again
the people who deny the reality of the
sexes
and the differences between them who are
today canceled
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there